herzlich willkommen im cellican Valley
ich wusste nicht dass er so scharf drauf
seid uns hier in Waghäusel zu besuchen
ihr könnt uns auch ganz normal durch die
Eingangstür besuchen und zwar am ersten
und zweiten april bei unserem plant day
in Waghäusel ihr könnt auch jemand
mitnehmen die ganze Familie
an unserem diesjährigen plante in
Waghäusel zeigen euch alles rund um
raspberry und alles was wir hier
schaffen haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unsere gartenbauingenieurin bei
raspberry sie zeigt euch alles rund um
dies birds in butterflies warum ist
wichtig ist das ganze Jahr über blühende
Pflanzen zu haben für Schmetterlinge für
Bienen und für Vögel die Pflanzen direkt
vor Ort kaufen und die innen war zeigt
euch dann wie man pflanzt was man
pflanzt und wann man es pflanzt und ihr
könnt direkt mit eurem Anhänger kommen
direkt die Pflanzen mitnehmen wir haben
ganz ganz tolle Angebote an diesen zwei
Tagen kommt vorbei und schaut euch an
ihr könnt euch im kompletten Silicon
Valley umschauen wir haben hier sogar
unseren raspberry Store errichtet hier
wird es ganz ganz tolle Angebote geben
damit ihr euch wirklich für die Garten
dieser komplett vorbereiten könnt und
wir zeigen euch warum und wie wir weit
was produziert haben der
Premiumhersteller Husqvarna wird an
beiden Tagen da sein und euch die
neueste Generation der akkubetriebenen
Geräte zeigen das heißt wenn euch schon
immer mal für einen
Automower also ein Rasenmäher Roboter
interessiert habt oder hier für so ein
elektrischen Vertikutierer dann sind die
Fachleute an diesen beiden Tagen da und
werden euch wirklich alles erklären
vielleicht möchtet ihr euren Garten neu
anlegen und vielleicht ein paar
Obstbäume oder bärensträucher Pflanzen
unsere Baumschule wird da sein und wir
zeigen euch welche Bäume für euch
geeignet sind wie man sie pflanzt wann
man sie pflanzt und was man vielleicht
pflanzt wenn er ganz ganz tolle Angebote
haben das heißt nehmt euch ein bisschen
Platz mit dem Auto so groß wie dieser
Feigenbaum werden die Bäume natürlich
nicht sein das ist etwas kleiner das
heißt sie kriegt ein paar Bäume ins Auto
rein und die können Sie direkt vor Ort
kaufen
Garten gehört für mich natürlich auch
grillen und der Michael wird da sein aus
Würzburg von wo grillküchen das heißt er
wird euch seine grillküchen vorstellen
und natürlich Dennis Dennis von Bitcoin
egg er ist meinst du bist jetzt Dennis
warum so halten
und zwar ein richtig riesen großen
Trailer und mit einer Hüpfburg und denn
es wird euch alles zeigen von Big
greeneck wie man ihn benutzt was es
besondere ist und es gibt natürlich
genug zu essen und zu trinken barbie
wird da sein Capri Sonne wird da sein
alle unsere Freunde werden da sein und
natürlich machen wir eine Charity Aktion
raus das heißt viele vielen Dank an alle
Freunde und Partner die uns dabei helfen
alles was mir an Getränken an Speisen
die ganzen Gewinne die wir erzielen
werden wir den Erdbeben Opfer der Türkei
und Syrien zur Verfügung stellen und
Hilfsorganisation unterstützen das heißt
wenn ihr mit eurer Familie kommen möchte
an diesen beiden Tagen können das gerne
tun es sind noch ganz ganz viele tolle
Aktion geben das heißt wenn ihr euren
Garten jetzt irgendwie einrichten
möchtet wenn ihr vielleicht so wie wir
im Grillplatz bauen möchte und sehen
möchte was eigentlich milbert ist was
big greeneck ist was Husqvarna ist dann
kommt uns besuchen im selben Valley wir
freuen uns richtig auf euch macht's gut
ihr Bachforellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]